um you've done a lot of interviews um I
mean God for so many years so what do
you remember like your first one I think
you're really young right yeah oh I
remember my first one just because I
still laugh at the headline it was in
the Dayton Daily News in in Ohio I was
living in Ohio and how about this weird
Helen oh
okay oh there it is
boy 12 sets his cap for stardom sets his
cap for starters setted my captain off I
win it sounds straight up out of the 50s
that's his caps G golly I know I was so
proud of that you would have thought
that was the cover of Time Magazine For
Me Oh no whenever I was I wasn't that
young but I did like I don't know in
like junior high do something for
singing and I you thought I'd won a
Grammy oh for sure I was in the Burleson
star and I was like I've made oh I and I
kept it my parents have 5 000 copies of
it it's awesome though it's like the
first thing you do that like inspire you
to like keep going it's fine it's really
fun you know you wanted to be an actor
very young I didn't know I want to be a
singer it's like I was a teenager I was
eight when I yeah I just because I went
and saw a local in Dayton production
um like literally a neighborhood
Playhouse production of Oliver and there
were kids in it yeah and like the light
went off for me and I was I knew that's
but at a serious serious level where all
the other kids thought I was like a
freak because I was well you had kids
and I have kids I have an eight-year-old
actually right now and I can't imagine
her just being like this is it right now
can you imagine yeah honey you have your
whole life ahead of you yeah you're
gonna learn about so many things but you
knew I was like shut up I'm gonna be an
actor
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]